Money can actually buy happiness, but only about 10% of it.
If you tell me how much money you make,
I can tell you how happy you are going to be in your life, but only by 10%,
because the other 90% of happiness is related to how you process the world
around you and your genetic makeup, which means that 90% is up to you.
Yeah.
Hi, I'm Amy Blankson. I'm the founder and CEO of fearless positivity.
I researched the intersection of happiness technology and wellbeing.
And today I'm here to debunk some myths that we've all heard and believe about
happiness. You either have happiness or you don't.
It turns out that some people are actually born happier than other people.
Some people are born predisposed to be more satisfied than other
people. And some people have a harder time finding that level of satisfaction.
Researchers found that only 10% of your happiness is due to your environment.
The other 90% is due to your deans and your perception of the world.
The key here is that it doesn't have to be the end of the story,
despite your genes.
We all have the capacity to increase our happiness levels and to practice
happiness. Overall, happiness looks the same around the world.
Happiness takes on a different sense of meaning and context of the cultures
around the world.
If you're a scientist and you're trying to study and measure happiness,
we actually look at something called subjective wellbeing,
which is the metric being used to measure happiness on a global scale,
through the UN global happiness report,
the UN global happiness report comes out every year,
reporting on the happiest countries in the world.
And every year consistently the Scandinavian countries top the list.
The question is,
why do these countries consistently show up as happier than others?
What makes them happier countries?
If you're familiar with Maslow's hierarchy of needs, you know,
that shelter and food are the bedrock of being able to reach a level of
self actualization on your life.
So having those taken care of and provided by those countries enables
individuals to pursue other passions that help them to move up the triangle for
happiness, but other countries that maybe are not as wealthy.
Also top the list what's interesting is that a number of countries who have
high levels of social support have been indicated to be some of the happier
countries.
So if we're looking for a culture that is going to embrace and to create a
global level of happiness,
the fastest way to get there is by providing social support to those around you.
There's power in positive thinking, happiness.
It's actually something that you can get better at.
We've learned from scientists over the past two decades from the field of
positive psychology,
that our mind has incredible power to change our scenarios and our life
situations. And we can begin to train our brains to think this way,
by doing a series of exercises that I call the J game.
It's a cheesy pneumonic that I used to remember journaling gratitude,
acts of kindness, meditation, and exercise the Jay game.
When I talk about journaling,
we're talking about taking two minutes to write down the most meaningful moment
in the last 24 hours of your life. What were you doing?
Who were you with and why was it so meaningful in doing so your brain begins to
relive the most meaningful moment of the last 24 hours helping you to actually
re-experience that because your brain can't tell the difference between
visualization and actual experience. And as a result,
we find that your brain begins to relive this moment and feel a double sense of
happiness. The second habit is G G for gratitude.
What we're trying to do with gratitude is to retrain the neural pathways in your
brain to begin to develop a new reflex and how you're seeing and thinking about
the world. We can't be both positive and negative at the same time.
So when your brain is practicing, scanning your environment for positive things,
your brain can't literally look for all the negative things at the same moment,
you're beginning to all of a sudden find new ways to scan your environment for
the good and over time.
This becomes a reflexive habit that changes your outlook on life.
The third habit is a for acts of kindness.
I recommend you take two minutes a day to thank or praise somebody in your
social support network you can do so by text,
by phone in person or even in handwritten letter.
But what happens when you send a quick message to somebody saying,
thank you for something that you've done, all of a sudden,
you create a positive feedback loop that not only makes the other person feel
happier, but it also makes you feel happier.
And so you begin to create a virtuous cycle. And for meditation,
I recommend you take two minutes a day to simply watch your breath go.
N S and out when you.
You meditate other people around you pick up the benefits of your meditation.
Even if they don't know you're meditating.
This comes back to something called the mirror neuron effect.
And the mirror neuron effect is an incredibly powerful response based on the
fact that humans are wirelessly connected to one another.
The last habit is exercise. Exercise is a bit of a starter drug.
I recommend that individuals pick one of these five habits to try for 21 days in
your life. This is up to you and you can get better at happiness.
If you make happiness into a work ethic, success leads to happiness.
Researchers have since found that the exact opposite is true.
Happiness leads to success. We keep thinking,
I'll be happy when I'll be happy. When I get good grades,
or I'll be happy when I get into college.
And then you get into college and suddenly you need to get a job,
and then you need to get a promotion, and then you need to buy a house.
And each time happiness gets pushed over the cognitive horizon and your brain
never actually gets to that feeling of happiness.
The reason why is because we're chasing after perhaps the wrong things.
When we look after success as something that leads to greater happiness,
we're constantly looking for external validation for our overall happiness,
but if we can positively identify the correct things that actually drive meaning
and satisfaction on a deeper level,
then we're actually moving towards being the person that we want to be.
Those are the things that create longterm satisfaction.
Happiness, money can't buy happiness. Money can actually buy it.
Happiness, but only about 10% of it. If you tell me how much money you make,
I can tell you how happy you are going to be in your life, but only by 10%,
because the other 90% of happiness is related to how you process the world
around you and your genetic makeup, which means that 90% is up to you.
So no matter how many houses you buy, how many planes you own,
it won't necessarily impact your happiness. And in fact,
it might have a decreasing effect.
Research finds the individuals who are more wealthy,
actually reach a point at which their happiness begins to decline with
increasing money.
We find that there's the law of diminishing returns and economics that says that
there is a benefit to things like money for a certain amount of time.
And then after a certain point,
there's a steep drop off social media makes us unhappy.
Many individuals feel as though social media is making us less happy overall
by creating levels of social comparison,
creating an increasing cyber bullying and leading to a lot of insecurities
about privacy. But social media is not to blame. It's about how we use it.
Challenges of social media is a level of social comparison,
always looking to other individuals in your immediate environment,
who perhaps are living a better life or their lives seemingly are
perfect. But when we look at our own lives,
we start to wonder maybe I should be doing something different and you feel less
satisfied the fastest way to make someone less happy is to compare them to
someone else. We often say that comparison is the thief of joy.
So looking at social media,
the key is to be able to limit the amount of time and exposure
to social media that actually benefits you. That helps you feel connected.
And the moment at which you begin to find yourself comparing to somebody else to
step away. And maybe even if you need to take a digital detox,
thanks so much for tuning in today.
My goal is to leave you feeling empowered and to know that you can make a
difference in your happiness levels,
that it is within reach and that you can become a best version of yourself by
striving after your potential.
Good luck.